a Tennessee woman serving a life
sentence for murder will regain her
freedom
following a high-profile campaign for
clemency Tennessee Governor Bill Haslam
yesterday ordered an early release for
30 year olds and Toya Brown she shot and
killed a man who she thought was going
to kill her after he solicited her for
sex when she was 16 years old her case
fueled the debate over harsh sentences
for minors and drew national attention
with the support of celebrities like
LeBron James and Rihanna CBS this
morning Saturday co-host Michelle Miller
shows us what's next for Brown Michelle
good morning good morning well one of
Brown's attorney says she was dancing
when they told her she'd be released in
August in his decision governor Haslam
called Browns life sentence too harsh
and says she's taken extraordinary steps
to rebuild her life during her nearly 15
years behind bars and Toya Brown pleaded
for forgiveness I do pray that you show
me mercy men should give me a second
chance that is my prayer on Monday
Governor Bill Haslam responded commuting
Brown's life sentence
Houston Gordon is one of Brown's
attorneys to see the absolute joy
flowing from her and then to see her
give the glory to her maker was worth it
all to me in this 2011 documentary Brown
recalled an encounter when she was 16
years old and a victim of human
trafficking she was forced to sell her
body by its hemp name cutthroats she
claims one night Johnny Allen a 43 year
old real estate agent picked her up in
2004 in an area of Nashville known for
prostitution
she says Allen agreed to pay her a
hundred and fifty dollars with the
intent to have sex and drove her to his
home just grabbed me like in between my
legs like he just grabbed the wrong
he just gave me this look he rolls over
and reaches like he's reaching to the
side of bed or something so I'm thinking
oh he's not gonna hit me he's gonna get
a gun and what did you do at that time I
just grabbed a gun and I shot on Alan's
family and friends joined prosecutors in
pushing back on Browns argument she shot
Alan in self-defense
Brown drew support from criminal justice
reform advocates and celebrities many of
whom expressed their reactions on social
media following Governor Haslam's
decision on Monday while in prison
Brown earned her associate degree with a
4.0 GPA she's expected to earn a
bachelor's degree in May and plans to
pay her education forward in a statement
released by her attorney she said quote
I am committed to live the rest of my
life helping others especially young
people
Centaurus transformation is nothing
short of a miracle
I look forward to seeing some Toya keep
people out of where she has been Brown
will be released from prison on August
7th and will stay on parole for ten
years but under the conditions she does
not violate any laws has a job and goes
to counseling sessions without Governor
Haslam's commutation Brown would not
have been eligible for parole until she
turns sixty-seven years old and really
the truth of the matter is at the center
of this case is believability
yeah leave ability of a young woman who
was involved in a human trafficking yeah
she had a lot of people who believed her
I've been following this case for a long
time and I know that there are many
questions here but the sentence never
made any sense that she was 16 at the
time that she seemed to be held against
her will but there are a lot of
questions in the case but a lot of
people are celebrating this decision
today yeah they certainly are
that's the country very different
sentencing laws in place will seem to be
very unfair Thank You Michelle